[Music]
hello everybody
welcome to this chess for nights
lecture where we're gonna take a look
on the one of the most trendy sicilians
there's
pesnikos sicilian it's uh cecilia that
for example
magnus carlsen the world champion has
employed
in several occasions in the last years
for example
in the world championship match against
fabiano caruana
so i see some people already in the chat
my friend go routines what's up
and hopefully you guys will give me some
suggestions
if you have any questions during this
lecture don't hesitate to ask me
i'm just here for you guys otherwise
there's no point right this is just a
lecture where
it's very important to interact yeah
okay the title hasn't changed that
that's right
so i'm gonna tell tracy
at some point anyway it's completely
fine
let's start with the lecture so what is
this vashnikov well it's
sicilian so e4 c5 knight f3 knight c6
and d4 as i told you in the previous
lecture bishop p5
leads to the rossolimo variation which
is
a more positional approach right
basically
what you want to do is just to go sure
castle and then in many positions you're
gonna give up the bishop
but in return you ruin black pawn
structure on the queen side right
because black will have
some double pawns on the c file so
d4 instead ct xd4
knight takes e4 not f6
knight c3 and here again different
options d6
leads to the classical sicilian
g6 this transposes to the accelerated
dragon
and e5 this is the so-called oh
there's something going on here
e5 this leads to the so-called specinic
of
sicilian what do you think about this
move is it is it a good move is it
a bad move well it's clear now that
after knight takes
knight d to b5 the d5 square it's a weak
square
why is d5 a great square because
basically
whenever there is a piece a white piece
on the d5 square you cannot kick
that piece from that square with a pawn
that's the definition of
a weak square but what does the
black achieve by playing e5 and
weakening his uh
center well now this knight on b5 is
gonna be misplaced
because after the move d6 when black
kicks
this knight with the move a6
this knight will have to go to a3 to the
corner so
definitely this is not a very good score
for the knight
we have a question in the chat in normal
dragon black plays d6
then g6 that's right normal dragon
it's achieved by this order knight s3 d6
d4 knight f6 knight c3 and g6
this is the usual way to enter in the
normal dragon
okay so knight d to b5 in the especially
off and now
it's very important to play d6 in this
position otherwise after a6 now
white knight doesn't need to be
retreated to a3 but instead you can jump
to d6 and actually your first block to
take on d6
and then this position is very good for
for white
okay so black plays d6 and then we play
bishop g5
it's very important to fight for d
squared to d5 square
because it's a weak square so ideally we
would love to install
a knight on that square right so in
order to do that
we play bishop g5 to eliminate one of
the defenders of the d5 square well you
you can play
knight d5 straight away but now after
knight takes e5
you have to take with the pawn this is
another variation actually this is the
variation that fabiano caruana employed
against magnus carlsen
and now black black has to go back and
then this is the
a different story but ideally you would
love to to to put a knight on d5
so that's why you play bishop g5
now black plays a6 knight a3
and b5 what is black threatening after
this move b5
of course black is threatening this fork
with b4 so we have to
be careful and there are two options
here in this position now
knight d5 or bishop f6 i'm gonna give
you
a line that has given me so many free
points in my chess career probably
this is my best secret i have a full
video series about this in chess 24
and here we are gonna try to to make a
wrap-up for this one hour lesson
but what i wanted to tell you is that it
has given me
so many free points because it surprises
a lot
black's player there have been some
opponents that
have been playing the the the especially
god for 10
years and then they didn't know about
this line so definitely is something
uh that you can use to surprise your
opponents against especially
so bishop takes f6 now black is forced
to take with the g
pawn otherwise knight g5 comes with the
tempo attack in the queen right
so g takes f6
and now knight d5
so the specinic of structures are
extremely difficult to understand
why because i mean black has double
pawns we got this
weak square on d5 and this skin is still
in the center
and here black has two main options the
first one is to go bishop g7 the second
one is to push with f5
so let's start with this move f5 and
here
many people go c3 maybe many people go
bishop d3 but i'm gonna recommend you
this strange
looking move g3
very interesting move now black takes on
e4
bishop g2 is the idea and now
well black has different options the
first one
is to play bishop g7
and the second one is to play let's say
f5 what do you think about this move f5
what do you think about this f5 move
actually
it is made in four
and i won a game like that in a rapid
tournament against a 2000 player
idea is to go queen h5
king d7 only move queen f5
kini8 queen h5 king d7 only move and
bishop 83 checkmate
this is actually my game against a
player called fernando
roda in a rapid championship in my
hometown in granada
and the game finished like that so the
first trap
okay so after f5x bishop g2 now black
as i told you several options
so bishop g7 is the main line and now we
continue with bishop
e4 and here the main line goes after
bishop b6 we'll check that later
but first of all i wanted to explore
with you
different options so what will you play
with the black pieces here
we've got a question doesn't g3 weaken
the center for white well
it's a natural way of developing right
just uh
going for the fianchetto we see that
in in many openings for example in the
english opening you play
c4 g3 bishop g2 we see the fianchetto in
the kings indian
in the ground field in the
in different setups right it's very very
natural
to go for this kind of structures with
g3 and
bishop g2 and in this case makes a lot
of sense because
you know we put pressure on this
diagonal
so now what would you play here with the
black pieces
give me a different move than bishop e6
that's right so we can go short castle
here in this position
but this is a mistake now
black's idea is just to push with f5
right so we got this fantastic move
knight e3 knight e3
we put pressure on c6 and then we start
gaining control on the f5 square
so first of all black has to protect
this knight on c6 let's say with the
move
queen c7 and now we have to stop this
f5 move how do we stop f5 in this
position guys
how do we stop f5 in this position
you have any idea yes queen h5
in h5 fantastic move now putting
pressure
on h7 basically we're just threatening
checkmate in the next move and also
we're stopping f5 because we have one
two three pieces controlling f5 black
has only two pieces
so black can play f5 black has to play
h6 in this position and then we continue
with g4
this is a game between international
master ernesto fernandez
and uh 2200 player in the spanish
national championship like 20 years ago
or something
this is a variation which is not so well
known
and it's actually played a lot in my
region
because there was a grandmaster who
taught us
this variation when we were all like 16
18
and if you guys search in the database
you'll find a lot of games between
spanish people
white's idea is very simple you want to
open up the g file
and with this g4 move you're stopping f5
as well i mean black cannot react
easily because this knight on c6 is
pinned so knight e7 is not a move
as somebody is suggesting in the chat
because the rook on a ditch is hanging
so basically let's say the black plays
rook e8
it happened in that game so now
g5 pawn takes and then rook g1
very strong now black can't protect the
pawn
with f6 because the rook on e8 is just
hanging
and then next move is just to take on g5
even moves like
h4 are very very strong for example
let's say bishop d7
and then actually queen g5 followed by
queen g7 is just checkmate
what's up chess thinkers how are you
doing hope everything's fine
here teaching the class from the
beautiful island
of ibiza in spain
probably you heard about this island in
summer
it's a little bit crazy so many djs
but in winter is extremely calm and it's
a good place
to work from all right so
short castle not a very good move let's
just try to
go for the mainland so f takes e4 bishop
g2 and here
sorry bishop g7 g3 anyway
and black reacts with f5 i mean if black
does nothing your plan
is to go bishop g2 sure castle c3
knight c2 knight e3 controlling f5 and
d5
these two are the key squares in this
position
and then queen h5 and then
position is tough to play for black if
he doesn't react because black has the
bishop prayer so basically
black wants to open the position for the
bishop player right
so bishop work in open positions
who are the players this is just an
analysis of this position
i'm actually sharing my analysis with
you guys and trying to give you
a repertoire against this specialist
variation
yeah so magnus plays a lot this
variation you are more than right
so here f5 and now bishop g2
e takes sorry
now f takes e4 this actually transposes
to what we just saw but now i want to
share with you what happens
if black castles which is a bad move
why is this a bad move short castle in
this position
so how do you play here with the white
pieces
g file open not so sure yeah the g file
is open but it's not easy to attack
black skin right in this position
so how do we continue
this moment g4
this is too slow and then you don't
achieve anything because black can
always close the position with f4 right
this is a very slow plan i mean you are
not ready to start a pawn march
with a3 g4
it's too slow so maybe f4
yeah this is another mistake because now
your kin is still in the center and
actually
this bishop was locked by his own pawns
now after he takes
f4 this bishop has a fantastic future in
this diagonal
for example you take on f4 then bishop
takes b2 and suddenly you are in
troubles
right so just be careful like this
bishop is
not doing basic i mean it's a great
defensive piece
sorry bishop g for sure castle is a
great defensive piece
but it is not enjoying a good diagonal
after you play f4 this gives black the
opportunity to open this diagonal with e
takes effort
so this bishop suddenly becomes a great
monster right in this diagonal
so f4 is not the move you know
basic principles in chess before you
start an attack
you put your kin in safety
right so normally you control the center
you develop minor pieces
and then you castle right before you
want to start an attack
in the center or in some of the flanks
right so that's why sure castle would be
a good move but in this case it takes f5
it's great because after bishop takes f5
there is a move which is
very difficult to see but with this move
you attack
two pieces at the same time
in order to realize about all these
tricks
you always have to think about
unprotected pieces
what are the unprotected pieces in
black's position
you are right the only two unprotected
pieces are the c6 knight
and the f5 bishop the rest of pieces
are somehow protected this pawn is
protected by the king this bishop is
protected by the king this rook is
protected by the queen
asic a6 sorry is protected by the rook
so these two pieces are the only
unprotected pieces so
how do we attack both of them
simultaneously
that's right chess thinkers with the
move 93 which is fantastic
because now pressure on f5 pressure on
d7
black is not losing black has actually
several resources in this position
so how can black protect the two pieces
at the same time
do you find a solution chess thinkers
are you there my mind timpo 35 are you
there
how do you protect the two pieces at the
same time knight d4 is an interesting
move
queen d7 queen d7 has a problem
you know just deviation just simple
chess just takes
the bishop on f5 and then just take the
knight on c6
so 27 is not working i mean probably is
the most natural move
like to protect both pieces but it just
loses in the spot so
queen d7 is not possible the move bishop
g7
protects the knight on c6 you just
retreated your bishop from f5 but the
problem with bishop d7
is that now d6 is hanging so problems
problems
problems for black but there is a very
interesting move in this position
which is knight e7
and probably some of you at home are
saying come on pepe stupid spanish guy
i mean you just blunted the rook so for
example i just take your bishop on f5
knight takes f5 and then bishop a8 and
white's winning well
this is actually very dangerous for
white and i'll try to explain you why
free and keto bishop some in some cases
can be as strong
as rook it's an extremely important
piece
all the time fiance told bishops are
very important
so so the problem with bishop takes aaa
this queen takes a8 probably you'll say
okay pepe i just go
short castle but then after knight d4
black is actually threatening to go nada
3 and then
g2 and h1 are the only available squares
for white
and some discovered checks are going to
happen well
you could say all right pepe so i just
play f3 i use facundo
and nothing happens but then there is a
very strong move in this position
actually when i was starting to play
this line when i was like
14 years old that means like almost 20
years ago
i had this position in the board and
luckily my opponent didn't go for the
best move for black in this position
do you find the best move for black in
this position it's clear
that black has to react dynamically
otherwise we're just gonna play c3 kick
this knight and then
bring this knight to the action knight
c2 knight e3 queen d2 rook d1
and white is a clean exchange up but
there is a
very strong move for black in this
position and my friend
cuckoo knight he just saw it
that's right e4 super strong move
smash that f3 facondo that's right
f3 open the position opening the
position now
if white takes on e4 then queen takes it
to sorry e4
and this is extremely dangerous for
white i mean the threat
is just 92 and after king f2 just bishop
d4 with the
with the checkmate and if you go c3 then
you got this fantastic move well i'm not
gonna tell you
you guys find it how does black win in
this position
come on cougar knight you're super
strong just find the best move here
for black find the best move for black
do you see it b4 that's right
b4 fantastic move boom
because now if y takes this pawn on b4
then 92 kin f2 bishop d4
and white has to sacrifice the queen on
d4
but the thing is i mean what should
white play in this position if white
takes on d4
then bishop takes d4 again the only move
is rook
f2 and then you can take on a3 and then
you're gonna take on f2 and black is
much better let's say
b3 basically you are not in a hurry to
check on f2
for example rook c8 and then if you try
to unpin with queen f1
then you have queen h1 also bishop f2
followed by rook c2 is just
completely winning for black in this
position
so i was so lucky my opponent didn't go
for e4 but it was a crushing move
actually
uh well it's not very hard to to
to remember all of this just taking
account that
you know in this position after g3
normally black plays
bishop g7 well knight d5 bishop g7 g3
this is our setup f5 we go bishop g2
now black castles yeah black castles and
then we check on f5 bishop takes f5
knight e3
we attack both pieces now black protects
with knight e7 and then
we have to remember that we don't need
to take on a8
immediately the best move
yeah actually i mean this happened in
two three games that i played
like one of them was like three years
ago and the first one was like 20 years
ago
so i have played this line many many
times it has given me
so many free points that's what i want
to share with you guys
so queen d3 is the best move
intermediate move attack in the night
now if black goes knight d4
we first kick this knight and now when
the knight
goes back now we are ready to take on a8
right and at the queen ahead we can go
short castle or even
long castle and we don't have the same
problems
as we did before okay
so let's check
the main line well not the main line
let's check another possibility for
black so
sure castle here we said
it takes f5 is a good move because if
black takes on f5 we just play knight e3
but there is a very interesting move for
black here in this position which is
e4 i had this position
in the capolanca memorial which is one
of the best tournament in latin america
which is played in cuba
illamana very nice country with
very friendly people
and a country that loves chess actually
every person in lavana knows who is
lanier dominguez this doesn't happen in
spain nobody knows in spain who is paco
vallejo
who is david anton well some people but
then
in cuba in lavana people breathe chess
you know like you're gonna ask you can
talk about chess with the taxi driver
you know everybody knows who's lanier
dominguer or bruzon
or jose raul capablanca so e4
very interesting move my opponent was
roberto garcia pantoja which is a cuban
grandmaster
and then i mean we have a problem with
the white pieces because
i mean taking this pawn is very risky
because our king is
still in the center black is targeting
the b2 pawn
so what should we play with the white
pieces in this position
by the way guys in two hours i think
let me think so okay we finish at nine
then no no in
two and a half hours we'll have the
puzzlers paradise lecture
where we will be solving puzzles
actually we'll take a look on the
sacrifices against the castle king
so this is what we're gonna do today in
that lecture
so hope to see you there so what do you
what do you play here with the white
pieces
the best move here is queen h5
just ignoring completely this threat
because if black takes on b2
then there is this move which wins the
game
f6 now the threat is just to go queen g5
followed by queen g7 so black has to
take on f6
and now we play bishop e4 next move is
queen h7 and then this position is much
better for white
what's wrong with c3
in this position well not nothing's
wrong but now black can take on f5
and we don't have our small trick
knight e3 because now 93 doesn't work
c6 is actually protected so black can go
back with bishop g6
and then the next move he can push with
f5 and then
black is restricting this bishop on g2
so
i would say well black is perfectly fine
black has to be a little bit careful
with this queen d5 check but
he can prepare f5 he can play knight
fight for example
just looking for the weak squares on f3
on d3
and black is just in good shape in this
position
alright guys so queen h5 the best move
in this position
just remember that let's go for the main
line which is
very very beautiful so f5 bishop g2
ponte xe4 bishop takes e4 and bishop e6
what do you play in this position what
do you think about this move knight f6
because it looks that we we material
after that move
would you go for this move knight f6 or
not
let me calculate oh of course take your
time just
guys take a minute or a couple of
minutes would you go for knight f6 in
this position
well yeah not f6
black has to take either with the queen
of the patient right
so let's let's go for this so knight f6
let's say bishop f6 you can also play
kin f8 but actually will transpose to
the same line so bishop f6
bishop c6 check and then let's say keen
e7
what do you think about this position
who's better here
is white better black's better in this
position
i mean for those who are starting with
chess it's very tough
to you know to understand imbalances
you know black is better that's right
chess thinkers because you know the
light squares
are extremely weak and this bishop is
stronger than a rook in these positions
you got
so many tricks i mean after sure castle
you can get the exchange back if you
want the
bishop of h3 sorry but you can also try
to push with
h5 h4 try to open some files and then
this knight is basically doing nothing
on a3
so i would take black so that's why
after bishop e6 nobody plays knight f6
in this position
so we play queen h5 and this is why
this line is so annoying for black
because
it's gonna be impossible for black to go
short castle
in the next moves because of queen takes
h7 right so normally
black goes rook c8 in this position and
then we go
short castle and this knight is
extremely annoying for black so that's
why
black ghost knight is seven i mean black
first had to go rook c8 otherwise
after 97 queen e7 bishop a8 was just
winning
so that's why black has to go rook c8
first
here we are forced to take on e7 and
queen takes c7
what do you think is black's next move
in this position
i mean we do something like c3
which is natural right because we want
to bring this knight to the action
but what do you think is black's best
move after c3
actually black is better already because
c3 is very inaccurate in this position
i mean the fight the fight has to
take place in the center in the d5
square that's right my man
kuku knight actually after d5
black is much better black has the
bishop black has a nice center
so we have to play prophylactically
prophylaxis
a very important part of chess so how do
we stop d5
now you see that there's always a reason
behind every move in
in chess in chess theory i mean it's not
always
good just to remember the moves but also
to understand
why people play like this rook d1 that's
right
that's perfect rook a to d1 this is the
best move in the position just topping
d5 but you know black could insist
on playing d5 how do we insist
with the black pieces how do we threaten
d5 in the next move
you guys are following the lecture
pretty well i'm pretty happy about this
i'm very proud of you
so f5 actually it's illegal
chess thinkers right f5 is actually
illegal
so not possible you are disqualified
from the tournament to the showers
so no no f5 but how do we
threaten d5 with the black pieces i mean
we have to reinforce
that square so how do we do it
i forgot about the queen on h5 that's
right and this queen is doing a
fantastic job not only is stopping f5
but also
avoiding black to castle because there
is queen h7 all the time right
rook c4 is the only choice that's a very
nice ride and this is actually the main
line
in this position rook c5 not rook c4
rook c4 just blunders the exchange right
so roxy
rook c5 very interesting rook d8
not very good because now i mean
i mean you can give a check on c6 and
for example
you force black to go bishop g7 these
kind of positions
are very good for white
because now for example we can block
with rook d5
and then finally we are bringing this
knight to the action and then this
bishop is not so good because it doesn't
have proper diagonals
and we have this tasty square for the
knight for example there are so many
universe
like later on where we can bring this
knight on e to e3 and then later to
to d5 so basically you shouldn't allow
bishop c6 check
so that's why rook c5 it's a very nice
strike
so then if black manages to play d5
then black's better so how do we stop d5
with the white pieces
and as you guys see this is a very hard
fight
for the d5 square so how do we stop this
with the white pieces what should we
play here
with white you want to go c4
you want to go h4 queen f3
well queen f3 actually stops d5
but now black and castle so we also
wanted to have this that key in the
center
i mean we are in a good position because
that kin is still in the center
so here i mean black can go short castle
and then in the next move also
black is threatening to go f5 i mean if
black manages to play d5 or f5 we are in
trouble
with the white pieces black has too much
space in that position
yeah b4 this is a very concrete place
that's why it's very important to know
this line
because these are not trivial moves
right before you ruin the your pawn
structure
on the queen side but i'm going to show
you one of the most beautiful sacrifices
in this line i have managed to play this
sacrifice
in at least two games
in two important tournaments so people
fall for this
so just try to remember this maybe you
can ride the bgn after the lecture
you go to another tournament and then
you have an opponent that plays the
especially of
this is real real material guys so just
try to
remember couple of lines and then you
already understand
the ideas and just try to use it you
know
it will make me very happy if i receive
from
one message in my social media saying
like pepe i use
your spashnik offline and then i beat
this guy
in this tournament and it happens
actually
so just try to use it so b4 now black
plays rook c3 attacking the night
knight b1 and now black can win upon
how does black win a pawn in this
position
yeah i mean the chess thinkers you
you have a point some positions you
cannot stop
d5 and then after d5 you're gonna play
bishop f5 that's
that's interesting too but here we have
this concrete plane
yeah no you cannot take on a2
don't do that because the rook on c3 is
hanging so
don't blunder the whole rook yeah let's
not blunder
the whole rook in this position
but we can move the rook
yeah you can only win a pawn by taking
it that's right so i mean
what i mean is we have a move where we
actually
attack two pieces and then we grab the
pawn
rook c4 that's that's right so
i mean my question was not the best
but you guys got me yeah so rook c4
attacked the bishop on
e4 and then the phone on b4 so we play
knight d2
rook before and we play c3
and we sent this rook to the a file the
rook is punished
and now this is a very
beautiful variation bishop c6 bishop d7
and now white plays
and there is a nice combination
what will you play here with the white
pieces
would you take on d7 we have to take in
account that we
sacrifice upon in this position wait let
me guess of course
take your time this is the key of the
position
and there used to be a time where
actually the engines
in 2005 thought that kin f8
was the best reply for black in this
position
but if you now turn on stockfish
then stockfish says that kinafei is just
losing on the spot so that's why bishop
g7 oh
i just showed the move
what's up stackert 112
all cool knight e4 that's right
94 sacrificing a whole piece
let's see what happens bishop takes c6
knight takes e6
check keen f8 and knight
f5 and this position is completely one
for white it's hard to believe
because we are a piece down but then
this rook is out of the plate
this skin stuck in the center we got
some rook d8 ideas
we got some queen g5 ideas with a double
attack on d8 and on g7
i'm basically white swimming i mean i
have to show you the lines right i'm not
gonna
tell you why it's winning and then just
run away no
i have to show you why so let's start
with the move
for example queen f6
this move covers g5 and then
probably black is threatening at some
point to go queen g6 trying to trade
queens
so what do you play here with the white
pieces let's finish this guy
so rook d6
perfect we attack the queen and
basically there's no room for the queen
so that's why queen f6 just loses in the
spot so
queen e6 now what do we play here
you want to go rook d6 again
rook d6 well that's a possibility but
there's a nice resource
for black in this position bishop e8
look at this move
look at this move rook takes pawn takes
and now we attack the queen and the
knight
so black survives but there is a better
move in this position now the queen
doesn't cover the d8 square so we go for
the check
on the eight bishop v8 only move and now
what do we play here we got three pieces
attacking the black skin
we got only one piece which is reading
some
russian poetry the rook on f1
well knight d6 96
loses why
i mean it looks like you want to take
this guy on e8 but there is key
seven and now the rook protects
the bishop basically
white is just losing queen g5 we got
always bishop f6
so no no no no no no no
knight d6 is not working i mean
what did i just tell you about this
rogue on f1 which is reading
russian and checkpoint 3 on f1
this rook wants to go to party you know
there is a nice salsa party
in manhattan city you know
song latin club so of course the rook
wants to go to that party you know there
is free entrance
for chess players you know but
i guess you're just playing with me yet
rookie one protecting the important pawn
on a2
of course not rook f2d1 just threatening
rook d6
and basically black has to resign well
let's try queen g6 for example
now there is this fantastic let's see
you guys spot this
this combination what do we play now
against queen g6
why not poor pawn the pawn on a2 at is
totally spawn
so after queen g6 you see the
combination
well i mean they're basically two
winning moves
but the idea is that is the same you
want to take on e8 kin takes e8 and then
queen f3
and that there's no way of stopping
queen a8 at some point you go
e4 you play queen f4 and finally this
queen comes through
that's right queen e6
not working let's check the last one
queen c7
here how should we finish
our opponent in this position
it's not so easy right now rook d6
doesn't look so strong the d8 square
is actually covered so queen g5
is the first move that comes to our
might but then f6
and if you go let's say rook d8 for
example then i can play bishop e8
and it's not clear so queen g5
is a blunder actually well you had a
nice position you had a winning position
now after queen f6
the engines say that it's an equal
position
0.00 so it's not queen g5
knight takes g7 that's right this is the
move knight takes c7
kintex c7 queen g5 check kin f8
rook v8 bishop queen 86
kini 7 and rook f d1
but what's the threat behind rook f2 d1
for example
if i play let's say something like a5
how do you finish the opponent why to
move
in this position it's very beautiful
it's more beautiful than la lambra la
lambra is
the most visited monument in
spain actually it's in my city if you
guys come to granada
in the south of spain we'll treat you
well
we got some nice food some nice people
not me but the rest of people are nice
well queen g5 i just go back i guess to
a fate so you have
to go back to eight six no queen g5 is
not winning
real or barcelona actually i'm a
supporter of uh i'm a fan of betty's
you know betty's is in the middle of of
the standings you know
so it's a decent team it's from seville
which is also a city in my region in the
south of spain
but actually madrid beat barcelona i
think 3-1 yesterday right
yeah 6 no no
i mean i can go for example rook g8 and
then after queen f6
i got keen f8 and nothing's happening
so no there is one killing move
that wins immediately
rook 1 to d7 well now you're giving me
a free point because i just take the
rook and then you want to take the truck
on h8 but then
for example i play queen take c3 and
then queen effect i can play kidney 6
and then you
you got no more checks so no no rook 1
to d7
come on guys 4c moves how many times
i'm gonna tell you this like thousands
forcing moves
threats i'm gonna give you that hint
threats that's right doctor
trip trip chance 1996.
what would divas do in this position dj
chess dog we got some people from the
spanish community community as well here
yeah rook c8 fantastic move
the queen cannot cover the d6 squared
and now no matter where you go there's
queen d6 just winning the game in the
spot right so queen gage is 26 and then
black has to resign
actually you cannot cover d6 queen c8
queen c5 not possible queen b6 not
possible
so rook c8 fantastic move
so let's see what happens if black does
something
i mean useful in this position not a5
so for example let's see what happens if
black takes
the rook on the 8th so basically we just
take on d8 and then there's a fork on f6
then we grab the rook on h8 and this is
just a much better for white
there is one last variation where
actually
black can try to go r1 to d4
what a nice move trying to save black's
position
then how should we continue come on
bedroos
i know you can do it you are my man
rook takes e8 well rook takes c8 rook
takes c8 c takes d4
this is a little bit better for what for
sorry for white
but nothing special so black can
fight at least in this position so this
is not winning
immediately well this is very tough
this is very tough but i think rookie 8
is enough to get an advantage
so i mean this was a nice try
okay but there is a much better move in
this position
takes d4 base range pawn takes e4
and rook e1 check the king is forced to
go to d7
and now come on now you find this move
this is an easier one
come on guys when i see a move like that
a little bit better i play no need to be
greedy yeah
but sometimes you know if you see the
nice combination just go for it and
just finish the game otherwise you will
have to fight for 20 more moves or 30
more moves
what's up i am genius chess 2006 queen
f6 that's right
and now double attack to the rook on h8
and also with the threat of rook e7
let's say rook g8 and now rook e7
you just grab this tasty food on c7
and then boom boom boom she takes d4 and
then
life is great okay guys so
i think this was all that i wanted to
show you just remember there are some
tricks
in this opening just the especially off
remember the line is with g3
and then many ideas if black goes
for castle then it takes f5 followed by
knight f3
if black tries to play something like
sure castle in this position just go
again knight f3 93 sorry
and then play queen h5 stop f5
and then after h6 just play g4
and then of course black boot normally
go for the main line then you have this
amazing sacrifice
you want to go deeper in this variation
just you can start it yourself
of course i have a full video course and
in chess 24 you're gonna make some cheap
analysis on this on this line
but anyway i think you are ready to play
against
this line and i'm sure you you will get
a lot of free
points i'm 100 sure
and i have a question for you mr cuenca
why is my chest form going up and down
it's like every sports you know it
happens to me all the time there are
some months where i think i am god you
know i can't i can beat every
26 hundred players i draw against
26 2700 players and then there are some
uh
months where i cannot beat even 2100
players
so this happens all the time depends on
your shape
depends on your mood depends on your
emotions as well
like of course personal life effects to
your play as well
if you are happy this will be reflected
in your game
you are sad i mean you will be less
motivated so you know it goes ups and
down but for everyone even from magnus
cousin so don't worry about that just
try to improve your game step by step
just do some tactics
but don't get obsessed with openings
this is very important just try to
understand better the game and then play
a lot of tournaments this is very
useful i mean if you read like tons of
books
but then you don't feel the pressure in
competition i mean
it won't work it's not the same to study
at home done
playing in a real chess tournament
feeling depression for the pressure
sorry feeling the nerves
you know having to risk in some
positions
where you have to go all in this kind of
stuff you know just
just try to to study step by step and
then play
a lot of tournaments this way your game
will improve
as usual guys it's been a pleasure i'll
see you in
a couple of hours i guess exactly in in
two hours
because we'll have the puzzler paradise
lecture
and i'll show you some interesting
sacrifices against the
the castle king so take care guys if you
drink don't drive
bye bye
[Music]
[Music]
you